ich habe letztens auf Ebay was entdeckt
was ich digitale Sonnenuhr nennen
Sonnenuhr Kinder jeder ist klar das ist
schon an sich voll geil aber die
digitale Sonnenuhr zeigt einfach sogar
Zahlen an basierend darauf wie die Sonne
steht und ja wie das funktioniert sieht
man ja so ein bisschen einfach durch
diese komplett wilde Anordnung weil je
nachdem wie die Sonne gerade zu gedreht
ist werden ein paar Sachen ein paar
Pixel ausgeblendet die Wissenschaftler
ist bestimmt übel heftig ich hätte aber
jetzt Bock auf so ein Ding und so nicht
aus Plastik sondern aus Holz und
vielleicht auch Metall oder so und ich
will es auch in viel viel größer als
let's go
dieses Video wird unterstützt von
Holzkern mehr dazu später wie eine
normale Sonnenuhr funktioniert weiß wohl
jeder die Sonne bewegt sich mit der Zeit
also bewegt sich auch der Zeiger
trotzdem eine geile Idee die ohne
moderne Technik funktioniert und bereits
vor viereinhalb tausend Jahren in China
verwendet wurde die digitale Sonnenuhr
ist da schon ein bisschen komplexer und
geht so weit wie das beurteilen können
in der Form in der man sie heute im
Internet findet auf einen kleinen
Youtuber namens mojopsticks zurück der
einen Genie sein muss und nur mit Code
dieses 3D Modell programmiert hat dabei
werden je nach Tageszeit und
Einstrahlungswinkel der Sonne
verschiedene Pixel blockiert so das
hinten raus wirklich eine digitale
Anzeige der Uhrzeit kommt ganz ohne
Strom ja und da ist auch schon das
Problem weil ich bin kein Genie wir
müssen das Ding einfach trotzdem selbst
modellieren man kann das Ding zwar
einfach im Internet runterladen aber in
einem Dateiformat mit dem unsere CNC
überhaupt nichts anfangen kann und wenn
man das Ganze aus Holz machen wollen
dann werden wir die brauchen weil
Handarbeit sich bei den filigranen
Dingern überhaupt nicht aber zum Glück
hat der du seinen Code veröffentlicht
indem wir jetzt zum Testen ein bisschen
was umändern können z.B das nur die
volle Stunde angezeigt wird und dann das
3D Modell selbst in einem Dateiformat
abspeichern können das später auch
unsere CNC verstehen wird zuerst drucken
wir es aber trotzdem mal schnell mit dem
3D Drucker einfach um zu schauen ob es
funktioniert also die Katze kommt gerade
ins Bild und ich werde jetzt dieses 3D
Drucker austesten moin solange da ist
also ich muss hier gerade ein bisschen
was verdecken aber hier ist es glaube
ich neun hier zehn hier Schalter jetzt
um auf 11 hier auf 12 jetzt 13 ein
bisschen Unordnung gibt es da drin aber
das wird schon richtig angezeigt nur so
ein paar Sachen daneben die beim Druck
nicht richtig gut gegangen sind das war
jetzt erstmal ein proof of concepts das
unsere Software auch wirklich
funktioniert und braucht man das Ding
ausspuckt und jetzt machen sie groß das
Modell haben wir dafür noch mal so
geändert dass es jede halbe Stunde
anzeigt und nicht nur jede Stunde und
dann auf fast den ganzen Meter hoch
skaliert und anschließend in einzelne
Scheiben geschnitten damit man die
leichter herstellen kann zu diesem
Zeitpunkt im Video wollte ich diese
Schichten unbedingt aus Massivholz haben
damit die Uhr hinterher so ein bisschen
aussieht wie durch Löcher der Baumstamm
und auf dem ersten Blick sieht das Ganze
auch extrem geil aus in der 10c jede der
17 Schichten dauert so zwar drei Stunden
was insgesamt eine ganze Woche gedauert
hätte aber das war nicht das Problem das
Problem ist dass egal wie fein wie die
CNC eingestellt haben diese Mini Stiege
sind jedesmal abgebrochen wir haben uns
also erstmal dafür entschieden doch 3D
Druck auszuprobieren und das Problem wie
wir das später noch in Holz verwandeln
erstmal der Zukunft überlassen
[Musik]
so sieht Einzelteile jetzt aus wenn man
es in der Sonne dreht das Teil sieht so
geil aus
und so sehen alle 17 Teile jetzt aus
aneinandergereiht für die jetzt unsere
vier 3D Drucker drei Tage lang fast
durchgelaufen sind wir haben dafür
einfach immer diese fast leeren Reste
Rollen verwertet deswegen sind die
Farben so wild finde ich aber ultra
hübsch ein paar offensichtliche
Nachteile gibt's aber bei der Sonnenuhr
weil wenn keine Sonne da ist gibt's doch
keine Uhrzeit und Mobile ist man damit
auch nicht genau deswegen gibt's
Armbanduhren wie die hier von Holzkern
dem sponsert des heutigen Video mit den
verarbeiteten Materialien wie Holz
Metall Stein und Helmut mit einem bei
holzkernuhren nicht bloß die Zeit
angezeigt sondern man bekommt auch ein
Stück Natur wie ich ihn einmal in der
letzten Videos gemerkt habe ist es echt
nicht gut aussehende und edle zu bauen
und beeindruckt mich umso mehr wie
hochwertig Holz kennen uns Aussehen
mittlerweile bietet Holz kann aber auch
Anwender Ringe und Ketten aus
natürlichen Rohstoffen und sogar
solaruhren die mit ein bisschen Sonne
praktisch ewig laufen über 1.000 Designs
bei Top Preis Leistungsverhältnis haben
wir jetzt schon eine Millionen Kunden
überzeugt und mit dem Code tomory
Stellen erhaltet ihr über den Link in
der Videobeschreibung ganze 15% Rabatt
auf eure Bestellung und wir sorgen jetzt
dafür dass auch unsere Sonnenuhr edel
ausschaut soll ja auch Holz sein das
ganze bunte wird man gar nicht mehr
sehen denn wir machen da so ein Furnier
drüber das macht man eigentlich auf
Möbel das ist einfach dünnes Echtholz
dass man auf günstiges Holz drauf macht
um das super edler aussehen zu lassen
für wenig Geld das kommt eben genau hier
so drüber was ich leider nicht machen
kann ist hier im Innenraum diese ganzen
einzelnen Stege einzeln mit Holz zu
verkleiden deswegen wenn die einfach in
der Metalloptik lackiert und nicht nur
gleich sondern eigentlich auch jetzt
sofort
[Musik]
es soll aber wirklich nur diese dünnen
Dinger hier hinterher nach Metall
Aussehen darum habe ich den Rest gar
nicht erst richtig lackiert denn darüber
kommen dann noch Holz und das schneidet
man jetzt zu
[Musik]
also bei der Form von der Uhr leider
irgendwie nicht so ganz hingehauen
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt hier den
Laser geholt und jetzt ganz versuchen
[Musik]
also ich muss kurz eine Warnung
aussprechen das kann ich jetzt extrem
Service fallen werden da sollten soll
eigentlich Holz sein so kommt er jetzt
ein Furnier drüber und das passt perfekt
hier drauf und sieht extrem geil aus
aber davor soll ich natürlich noch
Kleber drauf machen
[Musik]
Klebeschichten drauf gut und jetzt kommt
das hier drauf
[Musik]
nochmal
verklebt allerdings scheint gerade
draußen die Sonne und würde ich die
Dinge alle mal kurz zusammenschrauben
damit wir das Ding mal testen können so
wir gehen jetzt damit meine Sonne oh oh
Alter
16 also der Scheiß funktioniert und wir
machen jetzt hübsch
manu hat jetzt hier noch mehr funnier
drauf geklebt auf die Rückseiten und das
ganze danach einmal lackiert weil man im
zusammengebauten Zustand sei nicht mehr
richtig hinsprühen kann
und jetzt ist wieder zusammengebaut und
jetzt machen wir es auch von den anderen
Sachen mal schön von denen die man halt
hauptsächlich sieht also bei dieser
Seite hier da kommt das hier drauf das
alles abdeckt außer eben die Löcher das
schwierigste Teil wird definitiv das
runde hier
[Musik]
und weil Thomas das Ding natürlich nicht
den ganzen Tag in der Hand halten will
brauche ich ein Gestell aus
eichenholzresten die wir noch in der
Werkstatt rumliegen hatten
also das Hauptteil ist schon mal fertig
und wenn ich jetzt hier hinhalte der
wird auch eine richtig nice Uhrzeit
angezeigt
dann kommt noch eine Schraube zum
Einsatz
beim reinstecken danke
[Musik]
durchschaltet genau wie den anderen
coolen Videos ja die sollen spielen den
ganzen Tag schon nicht so richtig mit
und ist immer nur kurze 5 Minuten da bin
froh dass es Freunde also richtig geil
gesehen haben aber
wir wollten Himmel Design zehn von zehn
Umsetzung sieben von zehn
Praktikabilität ja zwei von zehn also es
ist mega geil das ist überhaupt
funktioniert aber wenn die Sonne bei
einer Sonnenuhr fehlt dann hast du halt
auch keine Uhr sondern nur ein schönes
Kunstwerk immerhin wenn ihr jetzt auch
was schönes wollte das aber garantiert
immer die Uhrzeit anzeigt schaut der
Holzkern über den Link in der
Beschreibung vorbei das war's von diesem
Video macht's gut ciao